[Music]
general aziz ahmed head of the
bangladesh army
and the man appointed by prime minister
sheikh hasina to defend the country
our surveillance team follows the
general to malaysia
and discovered that he's also guarding
his own secret
waiting for him is his brother haris
ahmed
he's a convicted murderer and an
international fugitive from a notorious
dakar crime gang
bangladesh police put him on their most
wanted list another brother is also
there
joseph was on death row but freed after
he was pardoned by
president abdul hamid in 2018.
okay oh my god we then tracked down the
fourth ahmed brother
alice as with haris he's on the run
after fleeing a conviction for the same
killing
of a political activist mustafa rahman
in dhaka
back in 1996 the men get a diplomatic
escort from the bangladesh high
commission
their bond with sheikh hasina began when
the brothers worked as her bodyguards in
the 1990s
in a covertly recorded call general aziz
says the prime minister recently praised
the loyalty of the brothers while
speaking to prominent members of her
ruling party
has been in hiding for 20 years
protected by the general
before he was part of a crime gang on
the streets of dhaka
now he says he can exert influence over
state institutions
we found haris in hungary where he runs
numerous businesses under a false
identity
he tells our undercover source that he
has sheikh hasina's support
7.2 million euros
also acts as a middleman for business
deals in bangladesh
the man on the left is hassan's business
associate
they think they're talking to a fund
manager in london who wants to invest
millions in a bangladesh hotel
to do something in bangladesh is really
great idea because he is
very well connected with the high
officials
very connected with the government
especially the prime minister herself
but the meeting is a sting set up by al
jazeera's investigative unit
20 position
he takes 20 from every deal
this is his brother actually basically
at this moment
his elder brother is running the country
in fact because our prime minister leave
everything to army chief around the
country
for the big developments al-jazeera
invited all those involved including
prime minister sheikh hasina
and general aziz ahmed to respond to its
findings
none did so will thorne jazeera